with a sneaky villainous twist and a
cliffhanger ending to set up season two
Jenna Ortega's gloriously deadpan take
on Wednesday Adams is plenty of fun
yippie kai movie lovers I'm Jan and in
this video I'm breaking down the ending
of Wednesday season one and revealing
the hidden Clues to the mystery that
even Wednesday herself missed spoilers
ahead of course so take care the Puppet
Master at the heart of the first Seasons
who've done it is Miss Thornhill
nevermoore's resident dorm mum and
botany teacher whose real name is
actually Laurel Gates although Wednesday
doesn't realize that thornhill's a
secret villain until Eugene says he saw
red boots on the person who set the cave
on fire as viewers we should have been
suspicious of her when she introduced
herself for the first time good evening
girls oh sorry about the mud in the
scene shortly before this we'd seen the
sheriff and his Deputy in the woods in
the rain surveying the crime scene of
the hiker killed by the monster so when
Miss Thornhill stamps her muddy boots
while claiming she's only been in her
Conservatory it's a clue that she'd
likely been outside in the woods near
the murder scene instead all of
thornhill's connections were dangerous
plants were hinted at right in the
opening episode when we saw her smiling
as she fed live worms to some Venus fly
traps Wednesday later deduces that after
Thornhill revealed to Tyler the Family
secret that his own mother was a hide
she used extracts from her plants to
fully unlock the hide inside him but
well before Wednesday figured that out
there were several Clues to miss
thornhill's interest in Botanical
chemical trickery most plants reward
their pollinators with sweet nectar many
carnivorous varieties turned to sexual
trickery or deception and the way that
hides effectively become slaves to those
who unlock their power this app caused
aside to develop an immediate bond with
its Liberator who the creature now sees
as its master was also hinted at when
Thornhill explained another trick from
the Plant World the Orchid produces a
pheromone own that mimics a female
insect luring the males in Thornhill
even gives herself away a little right
at the very end when just before
Wednesday's expelled she gives her an
Oleander Plant as a Parting Gift which
is Wednesday observed is especially
toxic but Oleander one of nature's
deadliest the body parts that Thornhill
collects and stores in jars are part of
her plan to resurrect her ancestor an
original Zealot Joseph crackstone and
there's a little clue to this earlier on
when she presents Wednesday with a copy
of the classic novel Frankenstein by
Mary Shelley similar to how Thornhill
brings to life the Monstrous crack stone
with a spell that conducts electricity
between the body parts you've been
collecting in Shelley's novel Victor
Frankenstein's monster was created from
a collection of animal and human pieces
and the idea of electricity bringing
Frankenstein's creature to life became
popularized after the 1931 movie when
crackstone is mentioned for the first
time as Jericho's Founding Father a
couple of banners for Pilgrim world are
unveiled with the words where history
comes to life together with a picture of
the long dead Pilgrim in a clever bit of
foreshadowing and a hint to his
resurrection in the final episode and
just after Wednesday breaks into the old
meeting house and comes across a model
of the evil Pilgrim she narrates secrets
are like zombies they never truly die
which is another nice bit of
foreshadowing for how crackstone Cannon
will come back to life as a kind of
Living Dead creature himself and crack
Stone's death at Wednesday's hands which
sees him burning up into a cloud of hot
ash and smoke was also telegraphed
earlier in the season when she and thing
set the memorial statue of him on fire
and the metal melted into a black Goo
now Wednesday Adams may be full of Woe
but thanks to the sponsor of this video
kamakoto knives you'll never have to
suffer using a blunt blade again when
you're preparing your next meal I got
this fantastic Trio of blades made with
high quality Japanese steel for my
partner and he loves the way they they
slice easily through tough ginger root
butternut squash pineapple and all types
of fruits and veggies each blade is hand
crafted using techniques perfected
across generations of knife Smiths and
Michelin star chefs all over the world
use kamikoto the blades have an
incredibly sharp edge that slices
through meat or fish like butter and
getting these thin slices of Sashimi is
so easy the knives will make an amazing
gift this holiday season as they come in
a beautiful Ash wood presentation box
plus each blade is individually
inspected and comes with a lifetime
guarantee kamikoto has a special Black
Friday sale on right now and all our
viewers can get an extra fifty dollars
off with discount code flick 50. so go
to caracoto.com flick50 to get your
kamakoto Japanese steel knives today
Wednesday prefers to do things alone
I'll survive alone I always have however
in the end taking down the villainous
Trio of Laurel the hide in crack Stone
was something Wednesday simply couldn't
do by herself instead it required a team
effort this was predicted early on when
she met Eugene for the first time and he
explained why he liked bees so much
their Nature's perfect Community all
working together to achieve a common
goal so although Wednesday confronts
Tyler alone it's one of her friends Enid
after wolfing out who saves her just
before he's about to kill her then when
Wednesday tries to take down the evil
crack Stone the villain smashes her
sword to pieces with his magical staff
and is about to finish her off but
Bianca stabs him from behind which gives
Wednesday just enough time to grab a
Shard of the sword and this time she
stabs him in the heart which as her
ancestor goody explained it's the only
way he will be vanquished Now and
Forever After crackstone's demise Laurel
decides to kill Wednesday herself but
this time it's her friend Eugene who
stops Laurel when he turns up with his
bees one says my only friend and if
she's in trouble I've gotta help her
it's Hive code by the way Wednesday
taking an arrow to the shoulder to save
Xavier from crackstone mirrors how he
saved her from the falling gargoyle in
the first episode the last few moments
of the finale leave us with some big
questions for a potential season two
such as who is the mystery stalker
sending threatening texts to Wednesday
someone who might be antagonistic
towards her is a siren guy Kent he was
in charge of sabotaging the other teams
during the PO Cup race however both
Wednesdays net and things punched to the
face stopped him and he ended up getting
the blame for Queen BB anchor losing it
was just your job to help us win and
she's never lost Wednesday also made him
look foolish in front of the other
nightshades when she explained how she'd
discovered their secret meeting room
then I saw the riddle wait there's a
riddle I thought we'd just snapped twice
well aren't you the brightest in the
bunch seriously even Kent is here how
exclusive is this club alternately it
might be someone connected to the
morning song cult run by Bianca's mum it
seemed like a weird subplot when this
came came up and I wonder whether it
will be explored further in season two
we are a personal development movement
that helps people take control of their
lives after you take control of their
bank account another possibility could
be the MERS son Lucas who got interested
in morning song via a self-help app that
Bianca's mum recommended to him his
father was killed presumably by Laurel
and although he appears to regret the
Carrie style stunt to the Raven he and
his two mates do have an antagonistic
history with Wednesday when she fought
them after they harassed her at the
coffee shop and the final shot of season
one has Tyler hulking out or rather
hiding out which makes me wonder if
Laurel is actually dead or whether she's
still alive and able to trigger him to
transform into a hide she may still have
some connection with Tyler and so after
he presumably breaks out of the truck he
could go and find her and together they
could plot their revenge on Wednesday so
who do you think Wednesday's stalker
could be and is principal Weems Real
really dead comment with any thoughts
plus season 2 theories below tap here
for my next Netflix video and if you
enjoyed this video do leave a thumbs up
I really appreciate it thanks for
enjoying Wednesday with me and hope you
have a marvelous movie loving week
yupikai movie lovers